lockerungen wann und wie experten
empfehlen der bundesregierung schulen
erstmal nur für die jüngeren zu öffnen
und eine masken pflicht in bus und bahn
zurück zur arbeit für berufstätige aus
industrie und baubranche lockert spanien
die strikte ausgangssperre
und tritt auch die förderbremse das öl
kartell opec und seine partner drosseln
die rohölproduktion wie nie zuvor
um den preissturz zu stoppen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem ostermontag
wann können wir zurück zu einem
einigermaßen normalen leben
dazu haben professoren aus den
verschiedensten bereichen empfehlungen
erarbeitet ihr rat an die politik grob
zusammengefasst baldmöglichst schulen
bis klasse 9 oder 10 wieder öffnen
zudem behörden kleinere geschäfte und
gastronomie
das gehe aber nur wenn folgende
bedingungen erfüllt sind
neuinfektionen müssen auf niedrigem
niveau bleiben
kliniken müssen genug reservekapazitäten
haben und auch andere patienten wieder
regulär versorgen können und schutz und
hygiene regeln müssen weiter
diszipliniert eingehalten werden david
sauer berichtet die krise nachhaltig
überwinden es ist ein hehres ziel für
das die nationale akademie der
wissenschaften leopoldina empfehlungen
gibt das älteste wissenschaftler gremium
im land sitzt in halle kapazitäten aus
ganz deutschland für recht wirtschaft
bildung und medizin zeichnen auf 19
seiten strategien zur rückkehr in die
normalität
zunächst in schulen schrittweise soll
der unterricht von grundschule bis
klasse 9 oder 10
sobald wie möglich starten mit
entsprechendem schutz ganz behutsam dort
wo die schülerinnen und schüler auch
wirklich entsprechend der räumlichen
gegebenheiten einer jeden schule die
masken tragen können dass man kleine
klassenverbände macht und dass eben dort
wie zum beispiel in kitas wo die kinder
die abstände noch nicht halten können
oder bei den jüngsten schülern ganz zum
schluss erst hochfährt
lockerungen also ja aber mit ständiger
kontrolle
wie entwickeln sich die infektionszahlen
und wie ist es um die disziplin der
bevölkerung bestellt mehr und gezieltere
tests sollen diese fragen beantworten
helfen klare empfehlungen der experten
außerdem der sogenannte mund nasen
schutz vor allem in bussen und bahnen
man kann da auch ein bisschen von von
unseren nachbarn in asien land ich denke
der mund nasenschutz es muss einfach
sozialer standard werden über monate
schon bald könnten nach leopoldina
empfehlungen auch gastronomie
einzelhandel und behörden schrittweise
wieder öffnen
da könnte man auch immer das muss die
politik entscheiden das ist ganz wichtig
jetzt langsam denke ich in der zeit
irgendwann nach ostern auch wieder
hochgefahren werden
die experten haben ihre empfehlungen
abgegeben das ohr der politik ist ihnen
sicher die bundeskanzlerin hat bereits
angekündigt das papier zur grundlage der
deutschen exit-strategie zu machen
für die psyche sei es wichtig das
betonen die experten außerdem einen
realistischen zeitplan vermittelt zu
bekommen wie lange der weg zurück zur
normalität noch dauert am mittwoch wird
die bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten beraten
aber schon jetzt ist die diskussion voll
im gange wie es nach dem 19 april weiter
gibt elisabeth schmidt berichtet ostern
als stresstest mindestens anderthalb
meter abstand beim eisschlecken oder
sonnenbaden wie hier am steinhuder meer
bei hannover überall in deutschland
schaute die polizei ganz genau hin
die bilanz verhältnismäßig wenig
verstöße und viel verständnis für die
kontakt beschränkungen so lange das
notwendig ist finde ich das völlig in
ordnung und ich denke gesundheit geht
davor eine leichte lockerung wäre
bestimmt ganz gut ich denke das muss ja
weitergehen mit mit dem geldverdienen
verweist der cafés und geschäfte aber
auch leere klassenzimmer und
kindergärten seit fast vier wochen geht
das so
bildung ist ein ganz wichtiges
grundrecht und wenn die hygienemaßnahmen
erfüllt werden können und die
voraussetzungen wie zb 15 kinder pro
klasse
dann ist es richtig dass schulen
schrittweise geöffnet
auch darüber will die kanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten am mittwoch sprechen
wir werden jetzt möglichst eine enge
abstimmung zwischen bund und ländern
suchen weil viele entscheidungen liegen
in den händen der länder
aber ich finde es richtig und wichtig
dass wir jetzt weil die komplexität von
schul öffnungen glaube ich die größte
ist die wir haben dass wir uns jetzt auf
den weg machen und dann weg finden
streiten den ländern ist allerdings
programmiert während einige nordrhein
westfalen etwa auf zügige lösungen
dringen mahnen andere dass wir immer
wieder schauen welche auswirkungen gibt
ist auf die infektionsfälle der ist
womöglich an der einen oder anderen
stelle in den nächsten monaten auch
immer wieder maßnahmen zurücknehmen
müssen lockerungen zurücknehmen müssen
wie zurück zur normalität es bleibt die
vage hoffnung in den ländern dass sie
diese frage gut miteinander koordinieren
wollen dass sie die gemeinsam auch an
treiben und vorangehen wollen unter
philipp gehe ich davon aus dass wir auch
zur einheitlichen regelung kommen können
ostern 2020 hat gezeigt die meisten sind
immer noch bereit sich an corona regeln
zu halten
gunther love energy in berlin da stehen
für uns alle wichtige entscheidungen an
diese woche was es zu erwarten
also zunächst einmal eine diskussion
darüber ob und wie man mit weniger
einschneidenden maßnahmen trotzdem
verlässlich eine ausbreitung des virus
weiter ausbremsen kann die experten
haben da ihre vorschläge gemacht die
haben wir eben auch schon teilweise
gehört sie haben aber auch ganz klar
gemacht die entscheidung darüber die
abwägung die da getroffen werden muss
die müssen von der politik kommen und da
steht eben doch einiges an wenn man sich
jetzt ein bisschen umgehört was wir von
politikern in den letzten tagen gehört
haben dann stehen die chancen wohl am
größten beim einzelhandel und bei der
gastronomie dass es da ein bisschen mehr
freiraum und herr vorgaben geben wird da
lässt sich wahrscheinlich auch im ersten
eine deutschlandweite regelung finden
sehr viel schwieriger dürfte es bei
schulen und kindertagesstätten werden da
kann es möglicherweise am ende auch
darauf hinauslaufen dass wir den
bundesländern unterschiedliche
regelungen finden die experten sagen in
ihren studien auch man muss eben im
zweifelsfall auch schauen ob man
regional oder lokal entscheidet wenn
sich das virus wieder schneller
ausbreitet wie man verfährt also sehr
komplexe fragen die diskutiert werden
müssen
am mittwoch setzten sich zunächst das
corona kabine
und danach die ministerpräsidenten mit
angela merkel zusammen werden das
diskutieren es muss ein fahrplan her das
sagen die experten auch und klare
ansagen damit bürgerinnen und bürger das
ganze mittragen einschätzung von chuck
unter lapentti aus berlin vielen dank
dafür
wenn sie noch mal genau nachlesen
möchten was die professorinnen und
professoren der bundesregierung warten
das ganze papier finden sie bei uns in
der zdf- heute- app außerdem die
vorschläge der experten zusammengefasst
in gesellschaftliche und wirtschaftliche
empfehlungen und auch heute gab es
aktuelle corona zahlen für deutschland
stand 18 30 sind bei uns laut johns
hopkins universität etwa 128.000
infektionen durch tests bestätigt als
genesen gelten 64 1300 menschen 3022
starben in verbindung mit dem virus
die ausbreitung verlangsame sich weiter
anfang märz hatte sich die zahl der
erkrankten noch alle zwei tage
verdoppelt nun sind es über 20 tage in
europa hat mittlerweile spanien die
höchste zahl der korona infizierten fast
170.000 fälle sind doch bestätigt es
gelten harte ausgangssperren sport und
spaziergänge bleiben auch weiter
verboten aber seit heute dürfen
hunderttausende erstmals wieder zur
arbeit fahren in den regionen in denen
ostermontag kein feiertag ist
wer mit bus und bahn fuhr bekam von der
polizei schutzmasken ausgeteilt mehr von
christel hass
alle die heute morgen mit bus oder
u-bahn unterwegs waren bekamen etwas
geschenkt das bislang mangelware war
eine maske das ist eine gute maßnahme um
uns vor denen zu schützen die symptome
haben in den regionen in denen heute
kein feiertag ist beginnt eine neue
phase der sogenannte winterschlaf für
baustellen und fabriken ist aufgehoben
hunderttausende dürfen wieder zur arbeit
voraussetzung sicherheitsabstand masken
und handschuhe
wir haben noch niemanden entlassen
müssen wir versuchen unsere arbeit
vollständig wieder aufzunehmen und so
unsere mitarbeiter zu behalten
es geht darum die wirtschaft vor dem
zusammenbruch zu bewahren
der regierungschef stellt aber klar das
ist nicht das ende der einschränkungen
kilo schwere mugler ich werde ganz
deutlich sein
wir beginnen jetzt nicht mit der phase 2
der sogenannten deeskalation phase der
alarmzustand bleibt in kraft genauso wie
die ausgangssperre kommt die nur ein
kontrollfreak und am wochenende kein
spaziergang ein sport das zerrt an den
nerven berichtet unsere mitarbeiterin in
madrid seit vier wochen dürfen die
menschen nur für das notwendigste auf
die straße auch kinder müssen zu hause
bleiben für die familien in ihren oft
kleinen wohnungen eine wirklich große
herausforderung
ein bisschen abwechslung bringt jeden
abend feuerwehrmann ohren
er hat eine botschaft die mut machen
soll denkt nicht an die tage die es noch
dauert steht da denkt an die jahre die
noch vor uns liegen
in südafrika gibt es im vergleich zu
europa relativ wenige bestätigte corona
infektionen noch denn die sorge ist groß
dass sich das vor allem in den dicht
bewohnten townships schnell ändert in
der enge und armut dort sind die
strengen ausgangssperren kaum
einzuhalten
mit zum teil erschreckende brutalität
überwachen armee und polizei die
auflagen aus der hannes burg berichtet
sandra theis es geschah am karfreitag im
township alexandra moosherr monza war
mit ihrer familie zu hause als plötzlich
soldaten kommen
ihr schwager bilder store schließen und
sich aus sicht der soldaten damit
offenbar verdächtigt erst hätten die
soldaten die räume durchsucht sagt sie
dann sei es zum streit gekommen
nom so mancher erzählt dass die soldaten
ihren schwager und ihren mann collins
brutal verprügelten er starb wenige
stunden später
er hat sich übergeben aber nicht stark
ich habe ihn sauber gemacht dann schlief
ich dachte er müsse sich nur ausruhen
weil er so oft geschlagen wurde
aber mein mann ist nicht wieder
aufgewacht auch sie wurde geschlagen
sagt thomsa monza und zeigt ihre
verletzungen
zeugen die das geschehen filmten wurden
von den soldaten mitgenommen
eine von ihnen spricht mit uns sie
möchte unerkannt bleiben
sie haben uns offen geschlagen dann
haben sie uns aus ihrem fahrzeug
geworfen nachdem sie alles auf unseren
handys gelöscht hatten
es ist kein einzelfall berichte über
unnötige gewalt bei der durchsetzung der
ausgangssperre gibt es aus verschiedenen
teilen des landes präsident rammer
passau hat klar angeordnet dass die
soldaten die menschen mit respekt
behandeln sollen
doch das ist augenscheinlich nicht der
fall immer wieder kommt es zu fällen wie
diesen wo soldaten exzessiv gewalt
anwenden und die menschen sind ihr
hilflos ausgesetzt sah mancher möchte
die täter verklagen
sie hofft auf gerechtigkeit vor gericht
gerade in den armen ländern der welt
wird corona zu einer existenziellen
gefahr für kinder war und das uno
hilfswerk unicef dabei gehe es nicht nur
um die direkten gesundheitlichen
gefahren
vielmehr drohe ein sozialer und
wirtschaftlicher flächenbrand der die
not der kinder verschärfe unicef fordert
schnelle international koordinierte
hilfe um eine katastrophe für millionen
kinder abzuwenden
die unsicherheiten und ängste in dieser
krise sind immens niemand weiß genau wie
es weiter geht viele fürchten auch sich
angesteckt zu haben und spüren symptome
wollen oder können aber nicht zum arzt
gehen telemedizin also die ärztliche
beratung per video bietet hilfe einer
bad bank
ingrid hempel hat seit langer zeit
chronische schmerzen deshalb
normalerweise hier in mannheim
regelmäßig zum arzt
inzwischen fühlt sich die 59-jährige
aber sicherer wenn sie die video
sprechstunde von dr weiß nutzte corona
zeiten hat es natürlich auch den vorteil
noch dass man keine angst haben muss
sich irgendwo vielleicht zu infizieren
angst die haben in diesen tagen
besonders viele corona dem alleinsein
der ungewissheit
diese diffuse bedrohung durch etwas
wogegen wir nichts direkt machen steht
nicht in unserer macht wir fühlen uns
wie noppen und das trikke dann alte
ängste vor allen dingen bei den menschen
die bereits in ihrer vorgeschichte durch
angst geprägt worden sind dieser junge
mann hat angst dass er corona haben
könnte und diese angst ist so stark
geworden dass sie körperliche schmerzen
ausgelöst hat obwohl er nicht infiziert
ist
mich hat beunruhigt dass dieses corona
virus das macht er eine art wenn die
kranken da ich auch durch diesen druck
in der brust und durch diese ganze panik
wodurch diese angst aber auch die art
und bekommen habe dachte ich das ist was
um den kollegen zu tun
diese menschen brauchen hilfe dafür
bieten jetzt immer mehr ärzte und
therapeuten eine video sprechstunde an
wir hatten bis zum letzten jahr
eigentlich nur einzelfälle die das
genutzt haben deshalb bestimmte
bürokratische gründe da wartet doch sehr
kompliziert und jetzt hat sich das
vervielfacht die nachfrage bei den
patienten ist natürlich hoch im
augenblick auch weil so viele mit der
einsamkeit nicht so recht kommen die die
korona zeit mit sich bringt auch eine
folge der korona krise der verkauf des
insolventen ferienfliegers condor an den
eigentümer der polnischen
fluggesellschaft lot ist geplatzt
lodz braucht wegen der pandemie
wahrscheinlich selbst hilfe vom staat
condor wird momentan durch einen
überbrückungskredit der kfw in der luft
gehalten
möglich dass der bund jetzt noch einmal
nachschießen muss condor hat über 4900
mitarbeiter und war durch die thomascook
pleite in schwierigkeiten geraten
die luftfahrt dass es eine der branchen
die momentan kaum öl verbrauchen die
ganze vom shutdown geplagte
industrie braucht weniger energie die
folge der ölpreis ist kräftig abgesagt
was dem verbraucher an der tankstelle
freut ist ein riesenproblem für die
erzeugerländer die haben sich nach
einigem hin und her jetzt geeinigt die
weltweite produktion zu kürzen um rund
10% tom hallo kathi details der liter
diesel für 99 cent wer gerade tankt oder
sich mit heizöl eingedeckt spart kräftig
während der korona krise ist die
nachfrage stark gesunken weil aber
gleichzeitig immer mehr öl auf den markt
gepumpt wurde stürzten die preise seit
jahresbeginn ab von rund 61 auf knapp 30
euro
um diesen abstieg zu stoppen will die
opec mit allianz partnern wie russland
die fördermenge von mai bis juni
drastisch drosseln um 9,7 millionen
barrel pro tag also rund 1,5 milliarden
liter fast zehn prozent der weltweiten
gesamtfördermenge ein historischer
schritt und wichtiges signal weil sich
damit auch die länder die auf
ölförderanlagen angewiesen sind und die
unternehmen dadurch stabilisieren können
und gerade jetzt in zeiten der grob
gewohnheit krise ist jedes zeichen der
stabilisierung ein gutes zeichen
doch experten wissen auch der ölmarkt
ist oft unvorhersehbar
zwar stiegen die preise kurzzeitig an
vielen aber danach wieder fast auf das
niveau vor der einigung
die frage ist nun auch ob derart
niedrige preise der nutzung erneuerbarer
energien und den klimaschutz schaden
könnten dann müsste man jetzt auch gegen
steuern weil die antwort muss heißen weg
von fossiler energie um sich auch
unabhängig zu machen von derartigen
möglichen schocks die nächsten wochen
werden zeigen in welche richtung sich
die preisspirale dreht die
verunsicherung bleibt auch auf dem
ölmarkt groß schwere stürme und regen
und gewitter sind über den süden der usa
hinweggezogen mindestens 18 menschen
kamen dabei ums leben
tausende häuser wurden komplett zerstört
die schäden sind immens von den
insgesamt zehn betroffenen bundesstaaten
waren zeitweise mehr als 750.000
menschen ohne strom
die behörden warnen vor weiteren
unwetter und es gibt noch neues vom
fußball zum einen feiert einer der ganz
großen
leider ohne gäste geburtstag zum anderen
gab bei hertha bsc der nachfolger von
jürgen klinsmann seinen einstand volker
grube hat mehr
bruno labbadia ist angekommen bei seinem
wunschverein sagte er
nach klinsmanns distanzierung von der
hertha muss auch labbadia auf abstand
gehen aber nur im übertragenen sinn
sieben ausgewählte pressevertreter bei
seiner vorstellung
die rettung vor der zweitklassigkeit
sein ziel wir müssen jetzt schon auf
knopfdruck versuchen hochzufahren
dazu müssen wir die mannschaft auch
stück hinbringen vorbereiten antreiben
motivieren und ihnen klaren plan
mitgeben training in kleinen gruppen
keine zweikämpfe aber wenigstens spiel
mit ball und selbst auf gehalt
verzichtet labbadia bis es wieder
richtig los geht's in weißrussland
werden die fans immer vernünftiger und
bleiben zu hause ein paar sind dennoch
gekommen zum heimspiel des dynamo presst
und 50 liebevoll dekorierte
pappkameraden sein konterfei kann sich
der fan aus aller welt kaufen und im
stadion anbringen lassen das
eingenommene geld unterstützt das lokale
medizinische personal runde geburtstage
sind so eine sache bei ausgangssperre
und kontaktverbot
rudi völler wird 60 und feiert
ausschließlich mit seiner familie
der heutige geschäftsführer von bayer
leverkusen gehört zu den beliebtesten
und erfolgreichsten deutschen fußballern
weltmeister 1990 als spieler als
teamchef im wm finale 2002 und seit
diesem tag weiß jeder
[Musik]
wenn das wetter morgen soll es noch mal
kühl werden aber nicht unfreundlich
details hat gleich gunther tiersch
marietta slomka freut sich auf sie im
heute journal um 21 uhr 50 und wir
freuen uns über ihren zuspruch und ihr
großes interesse danke dafür alles gute
ihnen und bis morgen wenn sie würden
[Musik]
mit anderen zuschauer stellen wir uns
auf das kühle wetter jetzt ein bis
mittwoch hält es an richtige polarluft
konnte aus dem norden über skandinavien
zu uns bis zu den alpen dabei ist
natürlich auch nachtfrost jetzt in der
nacht und sind doch hier und da in den
nächsten stunden noch ein paar
schneeschauer dabei also vor allen
dingen den mittelgebirgen hier und da
anfangs noch schneeschauer
südlich der donau gibt es in dieser
nacht schnee und regen meist klar dass
aber auf und dann wird es frostig
verbreitet gibt es frost bis minus 4
grad nur hier an der nordsee und am
rhein entlang bleibt es überwiegend
frostfrei und morgen haben wir einen
kühlen tag vor uns das sind dann meist
so zwischen 6 und 10 grad nur am rhein
etwa elf bis 14
es wird ein trockener tag werden mit
dichteren wolken von der nordsee bis zum
erzgebirge und ostbayern sonnig ist an
der ostsee aber auch hier im südwesten
zwischen bonn münchen und freiburg in
den nächsten tagen wird es dann auch
wieder überall sonnig werden es wird
wärmer freitag gibt es dann schon wieder
regen im süden
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie es gut